[Music]
more than 40 million tons of meat is
produced in europe each year for human
consumption animals can pay a tough
price in the system to meet demand with
intensive farming conditions making
livestock more prone to diseases
at least 20 percent of livestock
production is lost globally due to
diseases developed according to the
world organisation of animal health
animal welfare standards are key in the
european union's farm to fork strategy
so what exactly is it all about
we visited some pig farms in northern
italy close to milan brescia and cremona
where they are adopting healthy
protocols
for us animal welfare means ensuring
that within the breeding environment the
animal can express its natural behavior
that it can express at the maximum the
ethology of behavior for its species
in this farm close to cremona pigs live
in partially open-air pens and have
plenty of space to move around the
animals also get lots of straw bringing
benefits like the reduction of stress
conditions inside the barn are
constantly monitored including the air
quality and temperature data is
available in real time on the farmer's
smartphone
on this site specifically we have
installed a control unit developed by a
startup allowing us to check minute by
minute the main environmental parameters
of animal welfare
thanks to this type of management we
have significantly reduced the use of
antibiotics
the animal welfare chain starts at the
insemination unit this site strives to
be highly protected from pathogens
people can only enter wearing special
clothing and must follow strict hygiene
rules the cells are here for two
pregnancy cycles and are given plenty of
space
unlike the european convention that says
that she can stay in the cage for 28
days here we keep her only 36 hours in
the cage for two fertilization cycles
and then we release her and she's free
to go wherever she wants
next we go to a maternity unit in gedai
next to brescia here the pens are also
larger than those in standard breeding
farms the cells have what they need to
prepare for giving birth and piglets
have specific heated nursery boxes where
they can feel protected
[Music]
usually the sarah remains confined but
here she has the possibility to move
around an area of 6.5 square meters in
this way she behaves more naturally with
her piglets when she has to nurse them
she has a kind of recall action and the
piglets come out of the sky and go to
the sound to be nursed
better breeding conditions improve
animal health food quality and reduces
the need for medication consumers are
also showing more willingness to make a
choice based on the animal standards
applied by the farmers today the
consumer chooses a product not only for
its goodness it represents only 50
percent of the attractiveness of the
product the remaining 50 is given by a
series of values such as origin of the
animal its living conditions
and the possibility of having a fully
tracked system that makes a difference
on the market
countries such as denmark have already
implemented an animal welfare label by
2023 the european commission will
present a proposal to redefine the
current animal welfare legislation and
promote policy coherence
[Music]